in the last video you saw how to compute
the prediction on a new network given a
single training example in this video
you see how to vectorize across multiple
training examples and the outcome will
be quite similar to what you saw for
logistic regression where by stacking up
different training examples in different
columns of the matrix you'll be able to
take the equations you have from the
previous video and with very little
modification change them to make the
neural network compute the outputs on
all the examples on pretty much all at
the same time so let's see the details
of how to do that these were the four
equations we have from the previous
video of how you compute Z 1 a 1 Z 2 and
a 2 and they tell you how given an input
feature vector X you can use them to
generate a 2 equals y hat for single
training example now if you have M
training examples you need to repeat
this process for say the first training
example X superscript round records one
to compute Y hat one Wester prediction
on your first training example then X to
use that to generate prediction y hat
two and so on down to XM to generate a
prediction y hat M and so in order to
write this the activation function
notation as well I'm going to write this
as a two square bracket round bracket 1
this is a 2 2 and a 2 m so this notation
a square bracket 2 round bracket I the
round bracket I refers to training
example I and the square bracket 2
refers to layer 2 ok so that's how the
square bracket and the round bracket
industries work and so the suggest that
if you have an unvectorized
implementation and want to compute the
prediction for all your training
examples you need to do for I equals 1
to em on there basically intimate these
four equations where you need
I guess z1 I equals 31 X I plus B 1 on a
1 I equals sigmoid z 1i z 2 I equals W 2
a 1 I plus V 2 and a 2 I equals sigmoid
of z2 I right so it's basically you know
these four equations on top and adding
the superscript round bracket I to all
the variables that depend on the
training example so adding those
superstream round bracket I to X Z and a
if you want to compute all the outputs
on your M training examples what we like
to do is vectorize this whole
computation so it's to get rid of this
volume and by the way in case it seems
like I'm getting a little more of
nitty-gritty linear algebra it turns out
that being able to implement this
correctly is important in the deep
learning error and we actually chose the
notation very carefully for this class
to make these vectorization as as easy
as possible so I hope that great through
this nitty-gritty will actually help you
to more quickly get your correct
implementations of these advents working
all right
so let me just copy this whole block of
code to the next slide and then we'll
see how to vectorize this so here's we
had from the previous line with a four
group going over all M training examples
so recall that we define the matrix X to
be equal to our training examples
stacked up on these columns like so so
take the training examples stack them in
columns so this becomes a n or maybe NX
by
dimensional matrix I'm just going to
give away the punchline and tell you
what you need to implement in order to
vectorize implementation of this for
loop turns out what you need to do is
compute capital Z 1 equals W 1 X plus B
1 capital a1 equals sigmoid of z1 then
tap code Z 2 equals W 2 times a 1 plus B
2 and then a2 equals sigmoid of Z 2 so
if you want the analogy is that we went
from lowercase vector X s to this
capital case X matrix by stacking up the
lower case X's in different columns if
you do the same thing for the Z's so for
example if you take Z 1 1 z 1 2 and so
on these are all column vectors up to Z
1 m right so that's this first quantity
but all M of them and stack them in
columns then this gives you the matrix Z
1 and similarly if you look at say this
quantity you take a 1 1 a 1 2 and so on
in a 1m and stack them up in columns
then this just as we went from lower
case X to capital case X and lo que si
to Catholic 8z this goes from the lower
case a which are vectors to do some
capital A 1 that's over there and
similarly for Z 2 and a 2 right there
also attained by taking these vectors
and stacking them horizontally and
taking these vectors and stacking them
horizontally in order to get Z Capital Z
2 and capital e 2
one of the property of this notation
that might help you to think about it is
that these matrices say Z and a
horizontally we're going to index across
training examples so that's why the
horizontal index you know corresponds to
different training examples is sweep
from left to right you're scanning
through the training set and vertically
this vertical index corresponds to
different notes in the neural network so
for example this note this value at the
topmost topmost corner of the matrix
corresponds to the activation of the
first hidden unit on the first training
example on one value down corresponds to
the activation in the second hidden unit
on the first training example then the
third heading unit on the first training
example and so on so as you scan down
this is new indexing into the hidden
units number where as you do with
horizontally then you're going from the
first hidden unit in the first training
example to you now the first in the
human second training example the third
turn example and so on until this note
here corresponds to the activation of
the first hidden unit in the final
training example in the M training
example ok so the horizontal the the
matrix a goes over a different training
examples and vertically the different
indices in the matrix a corresponds to
different hidden units and a similar
intuition holds true for the matrix Z as
well as well as for X where horizontally
it corresponds to different training
examples and vertically it corresponds
to different features different input
features which are really different
notes in phileo
of the neural network so with these
equations you now know how to implement
a neural network with vectorization that
is vectorization across multiple
examples
in the next video I want to show you a
bit more justification about why this is
a correct implementation of this type of
vectorization it turns out the
justification will be similar to whether
you have seen for logistic regression
let's go on to the next video